hello welcome to this video this is an
update on my channel yeah and it looks a
little bit like chest to any for website
yeah this is basically what i'm working
on at the moment and i'm almost finished
i'm working on a pretty extensive video
series as you see this is a screenshot
IAM from chest 24 how it looks like in
the members section you will actually
see a little bit here on the left hand
side on the spanish opening where did
the german series last year yeah this
time I'm working on an english opening
series it's a big one like not sure
probably like six to seven hours and it
will be German and English language both
it's um it's a big project and it
basically took up all my time in recent
weeks so there wasn't much happening on
the channel the thing is I had to invest
all the time possible because I'm going
to a tournament later this week so I'm
damn i had to have to finish this before
i'm leaving so the channel has been
pretty dormant last weeks and I think
I'm probably it will stay for that for
two or three weeks longer because I'm on
that tournament and then I'm on a real
vacation that I think is quite needed um
maybe from a vacation spot I can do
stuff that depends a little bit on the
quality of the wireless internet um if
it's good internet yeah i might record
something i have to see i will take my
equipment with me but i don't know how
it will be at this place so don't be too
disappointed if there's a little content
if you are on chest 24 you have
something to look forward to with that
video series if it interests you the
english or play another thing that i
might want to add is that are now
regularly do been to blitz sessions also
for just 20 for the next one will be
this week wednesday the whilst at the
20th Adam this is 9 p.m. central
european time 3 p.m. in the US East
Coast the end will be right after the
bow broadcast so there's also something
that you can check out as an additional
live content the connection excess
the chest 24 website yeah okay this is
some what county happens with the
channel don't be disappointed justly be
a little bit patient it will be back to
an active channel again yeah latest time
for that to happen would be mid August
when I'm back from my vacation ok that's
an update on what's happening here
thanks for watching bye bye